While the live-action Mulan contains plenty
for both kids and adults to enjoy, some elements
of the film will only be noticed by adults.
From symbolic imagery to systemic societal
issues, here are some of the things only adults
notice in Mulan.
As Mulan prepares to meet with the village
matchmaker, her mother helps her get dressed
and paints her face.
During this "getting ready" sequence, we see
a number of laces and ribbons being tied tight
as Mulan grimaces, showing clearly how constricting
she finds not only the clothing but the entire
affair.
When she emerges, she comments to her sister
that the getup completely prevents her from
expressing herself.
"This is my sad face, this is my curious face,
and now I'm confused."
This isn't the only time that binding imagery
is used to convey Mulan having to suppress
who she really is.
Most notably, she has to bind her chest in
order to pass as a male soldier.
Later the removal of those bindings help symbolize
the "death" of her male alter ego, Hua Jun,
and the emergence of Hua Mulan as her true
self.
Once she embraces her identity, she undoes
the bindings of her armor and hair ties.
Kids will pick up on the idea that Mulan is
shedding a false sense of who she was supposed
to be, but adults are more likely to notice
that binding has been a recurring theme since
the very beginning of the movie, symbolizing
not just Mulan's internal struggle but the
external pressures of what society determines
women should be.
Mulan also makes frequent use of shadows,
reflections, and other ways of showing characters
indirectly to illustrate how they struggle
with identity.
Many of these devices factor prominently into
how Xianniang is portrayed, and in showing
Mulan's journey to becoming a self-actualized
warrior.
For Xianniang, whose life has taught her that
her choices are to either hide who she is
or be shunned by society, we frequently see
her through smoke and shadows.
Meanwhile, Mulan is often shown in reflections,
which highlights the incongruity between the
person she feels she is on the inside and
the image she has to project on the outside.
For much of the film, when Mulan looks at
herself, her reflection wars with her own
perception of who she is.
The choice to frequently portray the film's
two most powerful female characters through
indirect means helps convey their internal
struggles with self-image and their fears
of showing the world who they truly are.
Kids probably won't think to question Mulan's
unswerving devotion to the Emperor and his
dynasty, but adult viewers may wonder if Mulan's
cause is quite as just as she believes.
After Mulan is banished from her regiment,
Xianniang tries to explain to her that the
society in which they live has no room for
powerful women like them.
Together, she hopes she and Mulan may be able
to create a new society that won't reject
them.
However, Mulan doesn't even seem to consider
what Xianniang is saying, and she rushes off
to save the Emperor from Böri Khan's attack.
As a matter of fact, Mulan never once seems
to interrogate the idea of what unquestioning
fealty to the current system means for people
like her, even though she previously felt
stifled by that very system.
The Emperor seems like a nice enough guy,
but it wouldn't be unreasonable to wonder
whether we should really be rooting for Mulan
to safeguard his dynasty.
Granted, the 1998 film also never questions
the governmental structure Mulan vows to uphold,
but in 2020, it seems like a little healthy
introspection may have been both warranted
and welcome.
As it stands, it seems a little alarming that
Mulan fights so hard to maintain a status
quo that grants tremendous power to men of
a certain bloodline, while keeping women as
a subservient class.
While Mulan makes friends with all her fellow
soldiers, adults won't be able to miss that
the looks Honghui is giving Hua Jun contain
far more than brotherly affection.
Fans who interpreted Li Shang as bisexual
in the 1998 film will likely pick up on the
same energy in Honghui.
Although it's possible Honghui suspected that
Mulan was female all along, the simpler explanation
is that Honghui was simply attracted to Hua
Jun.
His demeanor toward Mulan remains much the
same after her true identity is revealed,
implying that his attraction was never tied
to her gender.
It remained constant whether she was Hua Jun
or Hua Mulan.
Mulan contains a number of impressive battle
sequences, but none of the foes Mulan faces
loom nearly as large as the sexism she encounters
in every facet of life.
Whether she's trying to bring honor to her
family through an arranged marriage or bring
honor to her country through her skilled fighting
as a soldier, she's constantly butting up
against the societal constraints placed upon
women.
She's told that her powerful qi is a liability
for a woman, although it would be an asset
for a man.
And during training, women are forbidden from
entering the soldiers' camp.
"Bringing women into camp or consorting with
women in any way.
Penalty: death."
What's more, this same sexist oppression is
what drove Xianniang to side with Böri Khan
in the first place.
She tells Mulan that she tried to find a noble
path forward, but it didn't exist within acceptable
society.
The only options available to her were to
either ally herself with an enemy of the kingdom
or deny her own power.
"The more power I showed, the more I was quashed.
Just like you."
Considering that Xianniang is instrumental
in gaining Böri Khan most of his tactical
advantages during the film, it's hard to ignore
that if society hadn't been so intent on oppressing
women, the Emperor may not have needed saving
in the first place.
The meaning of "true"
Throughout the film, Mulan is constantly trying
to embody the three pillars of virtue.
Early on, she strives to live out these virtues
and make her family proud through restraining
her impulses in order to present herself well
and make a good and respectable match.
Later, she experiences a crisis of conscience
when she realizes she can't possibly be "true"
while also deceiving everyone around her.
Ultimately, she comes into her own when she
rejects both the societal expectations of
women and the pretense of being a man, and
embraces her own unique skills and identity.
It's interesting that for the majority of
the film, it seems as though everyone in Mulan's
life, including Mulan herself, assumes that
being "true" means to accept her place and
to stop bucking traditions and questioning
cultural norms.
"You are the daughter.
Learn your place."
If Mulan had remained a demure and subservient
daughter, everyone would've thought that she
was being true to the role that had been given
to her.
But by the end of the film, we're shown that
what's actually "true" for Mulan is a path
that didn't even exist before she carved it
out for herself.
While kids will likely embrace the film's
themes of self-acceptance on a surface level,
adults are more equipped to unpack the complex
idea that our understanding of who we are
and how to live truthfully can evolve over
time.
In all the promotional material for Mulan,
it seemed as though Xianniang was going to
be the main antagonist of the film.
But by the end of the film, Xianniang has
seen an alternate version of herself in Mulan,
and she ultimately sacrifices herself to save
the younger woman.
Kids won't miss Xianniang's sacrifice, but
what they might fail to see is that Xianniang
was never really a villain at all.
Xianniang tells Mulan that she joined forces
with Böri Khan because he was the only one
who provided a place for her and allowed her
to be who she was.
But as we see before their encounter, she's
really more of a prisoner than a lieutenant.
"Now I know, I serve you.
I am the slave."
"And you would do well to remember it."
While she does Böri Khan's bidding for much
of the film, her true motivation is to create
a society in which she can be accepted without
having to diminish herself.
In Mulan, she sees the possibility of that
society, and she gives her life to help it
come into being.
Rather than an antagonist working against
the hero, Xianniang proves herself to be a
tragic figure who was ultimately working toward
the same goals as Mulan.
By the end of the film, Mulan has returned
home to her village, seeking to beg her family's
forgiveness for how she left and restore their
honor.
But when she's reunited with her family, they're
not angry with her for leaving, but rather
relieved that she finally came back home.
Her father then tells her that he recognizes
that she's a warrior, and that he should've
seen that all along.
Considering we've just seen Mulan defeat Böri
Khan single-handedly and get recognized by
the Emperor, this exchange makes complete
sense.
But what young viewers may not have quite
pieced together is that Hua Zhou wouldn't
actually know about her accomplishments in
battle yet.
As children, it's easy to assume that the
characters know whatever we know, but as adults,
the flow of information becomes a lot clearer.
When her father says he sees that Mulan is
a warrior, he didn't come to that revelation
because he'd heard of her great feats in battle.
Instead, it's because he finally admitted
the truth he'd always known about his daughter.
It turns out that none of Mulan's accomplishments
were necessary for her father to finally see
her.
He'd known who she was from the beginning.
By the end of Mulan, it seems like women's
rights have taken a big step forward, with
Mulan being invited to serve as an officer
in the Emperor's guard.
But while Mulan herself has come a long way,
not much has been done for any of the other
women living alongside her.
She returns home to find her sister excited
about her upcoming arranged marriage, with
the other women in her village still in exactly
the same circumstances as when she left.
Granted, none of the other women in Mulan
have given any indication that they want anything
else for their lives, but that could be simply
because they never considered that other options
might be open to them.
Xianniang, the only other woman who wanted
something more than what society was prepared
to offer, is dead by the film's end.
Kids may be satisfied that Mulan herself is
able to finally lead the life she wants, but
adults may wonder how much has really changed.
Mulan accepting her commission as an officer
in the Emperor's guard is presented as a happy
ending, but Mulan likely has an extremely
hard road ahead of her.
Remember, the army that she's going to join
is the same one that, earlier in the film,
reminded its soldiers that the presence of
a woman in the camp was punishable by death.
Although the men who fought beside Mulan against
Böri Khan are ready and willing to accept
her as a warrior, there are plenty of other
men in the Emperor's guard who don't know
her personally.
They aren't all going to be thrilled at the
idea of admitting a woman to their ranks,
much less as a leader.
Not all men will find it easy to let go of
the way things have always been done in the
past, and it's probable that at least some
of Mulan's fellow soldiers could decide to
make her life particularly difficult in order
to "prove" that women have no place among
them.
Mulan was able to earn the respect of her
peers once before, but that was only after
she'd previously earned it as a man.
Her new career as the only female officer
in the Emperor's guard will no doubt be a
tremendously challenging one, but we are sure
she's up to the task.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
movies and TV shows are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.